he won bronze in rio and sam kendricks
was on a mission to win gold in tokyo
but one positive test and it's over
two days before his competition i'm out
uh the same self test i took when i got
to isolation 10 days in isolation
i was a negative as well but for the
sake of protocols the japanese say i
am out i have no recourse
um but to sit in isolation and watch the
olympics
he's not alone but he is the most high
profile athlete so far
to pull out of the games within minutes
of the news
54 members of the australian athletics
team
were locked down in their rooms in the
athletes village
just as a precaution three of the
australians are still on restricted
movements because of the contact they'd
had with sam kendricks
they should still be clear to compete
but it shows how one
positive covert test can jeopardize
everything for the athletes
the americans main rival in the pole
vault from sweden was all set to battle
it out with him again
i think all of the pole vaulters are
pretty pretty spooked out right now
i was i mean i was gonna possibly meet
up with sam yesterday but i got a phone
call from dessert and my girlfriend and
then i ended up not meeting up with them
so
you know that was a i think that was a
that was a pretty lucky
lucky dodge right there on the day of
the opening ceremony last friday
there were one thousand 1 359 new cases
of covert in tokyo
by day 4 it had risen to a record number
2848. on day 5
it was up again 3177. and now on day six
it has left to 3865.
the olympic organizers insist that the
200 cases amongst games participants
have all been isolated but the protests
are just getting louder
it's contradictory to host the olympics
and try to prevent infections
because the olympics have caused the
public to feel relaxed
i think the right thing for the
government to do is to cancel the
olympics
the state of emergency in the japanese
capital has now been extended until the
end of
august into the start of the paralympic
games
the organizers are in unchartered waters
where the risk feels very real
tom parmenter sky news tokyo